yeah welcome to this video playing
Yardbird and it's offbeat openings time
which is not a good combination he's
really good at this kind of stuff let's
go for the l a-- kinds again this is I
really don't know I mean they're not
that many playable of bid openings
against them a forum and the alikan
maybe discount discount that one as
offbeat I mean yes so what is this CC
form I know where you go here maybe to
c7 it's not that I never played that the
Alec own defense i played it a bit in
tournament chess some years ago well
okay i don't think i ever lost the game
with it okay so i can take g for now is
this too risky hmm Nyjah 395 yeah looks
very very problematic is night e 60 more
voices completely
it's definitely playing with fire
against mr. mr. Yardbird but ok we can
click win a three year I was thinking
just f6 or something but this is
ridiculous yes Queen age five
should I play Knight g5f 6 Queen h5 g6
takes I really have no move right huh
this looks like complete nonsense but ok
what else the other the other moves
loose straight away this this might lose
as well with the other other thing was
just was just worse so 96 was pretty
better this is this one we now can say
for sure maybe I can take 10 actually
next move because no I cannot I take
here Queen takes f6 still queen age 5 so
I have to play this rubbish move or is
c6 I have no squares I have Noah square
said or f6 I'm sorry h6 maybe this is
really weird chest maybe I get to f6
yeah this is the LA kind nite nite f6d
5c 76 g5 and now it wants to go back to
f6 well belongs yeah here we go I he can
take them he's threatening to take and
95 and so Knight to d7 I guess which is
hopefully not losing immediately living
on the razor's edge
he's also better with normal moves but I
understand that he wants to try to to
put this away nice one nice one yeah I
cannot take this is made okay this is
totally crazy so much for cancelling
which one I don't know this one he can
take h6 as weird as it looks so maybe
let's take with a king
it's a particular threat or let's do
that I know it looks crazy but maybe I
can actually fight for the D Phi square
here nightby 695 I guess maybe here and
trying to trade queens okay takes 97
push-ups III i guess but is he
threatening anything i can go see five
let's do that
yeah what a garbage position him a 96
was was really bad that idea
abid white is just better after that
check and at least you cannot castle
cannot cheat unfortunately maybe you
should just take with the good end game
it's probably easiest
time warning
check well I think am I survive this I
ok three hands okay okay i forgot about
Luke a 3m ads unfortunately completely
lost as absolutely not even a chance to
fight with da porn
check any kind of trickery what the unit
check black resigns yeah the empty
didn't did it I mean I i think it was
playable at some point again from this
really crappy position check yeah
somehow this isn't that bad maybe queen
a forum here I'm worse but I still felt
felt like survive I don't know really ok
sc5 Kingda seven seems too hard I am
it's not exactly fun now I overlooked
okay three completely I thought this is
a draw yea maybe then c5 is good store
bit of a strange move yeah maybe I
should play this I mean yeah I had my
doubts about 26 but I didn't see that
move but that's just more interesting
maybe I can go here might be might be
some how horrible but the whole the
whole position is just utter crap yeah
996 is just a joke but I really I really
blanked out here Queenie a three-year
system I cannot take care that it's also
important to mention yeah I don't want
that coming but if I like if I go g6
let's say this is a relatively normal
Ella current position I mean like a
slightly viewers as he always is in this
opening but it's nothing
nothing dramatic at 96 what a joke it's
really surprised and somehow this this
stuff it held you haven't for for a long
while I know where did he do I did she
go wrong here mp3 here maybe 95 I don't
know somewhere out here we get this
position of the Queen a4 it's not that
clear here if I go Queen a4 yes this is
vid weird but it's it's not totally
clear the bishop is a is a difficult
piece at its it looks good it looks
strong but it's not so clear what it is
actually doing even this very ugly move
suggested by the Comets not that clear
rly by getting king f7 and see forests
attacked oh I don't know it's not really
beautiful but the engine gives 0.3 only
0.3 and that tend to believe the comp
and this kind of position it's
completely technical completely concrete
Wow okay well thanks for watching